Subject to the same rules of the road as other
drivers, with a few exceptions for emergencies,
ambulances can be pulled over and ticketed
for speeding and other traffic violations,
although it is exceedingly rare.
Generally speaking, ambulance drivers should
observe all traffic laws and regulations;
however, some of those laws are waived when
the ambulance needs to respond to an emergency
(sometimes called “Code 3”).
Typical exceptions (which usually apply to
other emergency response vehicles like fire
trucks as well), include: (1) allowing the
vehicle to park or “stand” pretty much
anywhere the driver puts it; (2) blowing red
lights and stop signs – after ensuring it’s
safe to do so (and slowing down); (3) driving
in the “wrong” lane or the “wrong”
way up a street or through an intersection;
and (4) exceeding the maximum speed limit.
Depending on the jurisdiction, with the exception
concerning speed, some limit it to 10 miles
per hour (mph) over the speed limit, others
15 mph, and still others leave it to the driver’s
discretion “so long as (s)he does not endanger
life or property.”
In addition, again depending on the location,
many states and localities require that the
vehicle “make use of visual signs,” i.e.
have its lights on and some may prefer the
siren to be blaring as well.
However, even in places where the siren is
supposed to be on, medics may choose to turn
it off, since the sound may disturb some patients
(as one EMT said, it “makes the patient
freak out.”)
Note that some of the exceptions to the basic
traffic laws have vague language, and the
interpretation depends on your perspective.
According to one EMT whose crew was attempting
to reach a site expeditiously, the driver
chose to “oppose traffic” (presumably
drive the wrong way down the street) for about
300 feet, driving about 15 mph; obviously,
that driver made the judgment call that do
so was safe.
Unfortunately for him, a police officer who
observed this made a different judgment call,
that it wasn’t, and pulled the ambulance
over; while she did not give the ambulance
driver a ticket, she did hold it at the location
well past the time for the call and, we can
only hope, another ambulance was dispatched
to the emergency.
Since ambulances are expected to behave as
other vehicles when not responding to an emergency,
if they are approached by an emergency responder,
like everyone else, they are expected to pull
over too.
In a 2009 incident in Oklahoma, an ambulance
that did not have its lights or sirens running
was pulled over by a state trooper after it
failed to give the trooper the right of way
when he was attempting to respond to a call.
According to the trooper, the ambulance driver
also flipped him off, so the trooper pulled
him over.
It turned out that the ambulance was transporting
a patient, but was not running either the
lights or the siren in an effort to keep the
patient calm.
So, as soon as the ambulance stopped, the
lead medic emerged from the ambulance to discuss
the situation with the trooper, but the latter
was too incensed to listen.
An altercation ensued, which escalated to
the point where the trooper grabbed the medic
by the neck.
The incident was caught on camera (by the
patient’s family who were travelling behind
the ambulance), and the trooper was suspended.
Historically, the medical community has held
to the belief that there is a “golden hour,”
in which serious trauma patients who make
it to a hospital within 60 minutes of being
injured are much more likely to survive, and
that the faster the patient makes it to the
ER, generally, the better.
For example, some say that Princess Diana,
who died in 1997, could have been saved had
the ambulance not taken 40 minutes to transport
her to the hospital (some say it could’ve
made the trip in 5 minutes, but took so long
due to French emergency procedures).
However, recent research is challenging the
assumptions behind “faster is better,”
in regards to the “EMS interval.”
In a 2010 study published in the Annals of
Emergency Medicine, after looking into the
time it took over 3,000 trauma patients to
make it to the hospital and their outcomes,
the study revealed that, extremely counter-intuitively,
“shorter intervals did not appear to improve
survival.”
However, according to the Chairman of the
London Ambulance Service, Sigurd Reinton,
even a minor delay from things like speed
bumps kills numerous people every year by
slowing emergency vehicles.
This is a notion backed up by a study done
by Ronald Bowman in Boulder, Colorado that
indicated that for every life saved by various
traffic slowing measures like speed bumps,
an astounding 85 people die because of this
slowing effect on emergency vehicles, whether
inherently, like in speed bumps, or by jamming
up traffic.